healthcare is very very um
it's a very busy lifestyle should we say
you know doctors are very busy people
and that's only going one way
so it's been getting harder and harder
for them to dedicate time
to spend with reps versus patients and
then you have you know a global pandemic
that you know locks down
the entire world like you know try and
get a rep in to see a doctor in this
environment
and you know that's really accelerated
things so
they're spending more and more well they
have less and less time to actually
spend with a physical rep but they have
more and more digital touch points
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to 20-minute leaders today we're
talking about physicians but in a
different point of view meet gareth shaw
president uk and europe of docare the
world's first global platform for
programmatic physician marketing prior
to docker gareth worked on the senior
leadership team at pulsepoint where he
helped scale the business to the point
where they were strategically acquired
by webmd
gareth has over 15 years of experience
in digital holding roles at yahoo and
experian it was at paul's point that he
began his journey into the health
vertical he has lofty aspirations for
the role that care can play in improving
health care globally through more
effective physician engagement
gareth shaw welcome to 20 minute leaders
president of the united kingdom in
europe of ducair how are you i'm very
well thank you thank you for having me
looking forward to being here
i'm i'm just curious to learn about what
it is that you do here because it sounds
really relevant to today it sounds it
sounds like a modern way of thinking
through you know physicians and doctors
and how they interact with the world
around us and how do we as the world
interact with them
and and looking at what do care is doing
with physician-only programmatic
marketing so
gareth first of all what what does that
mean
the care physician only programmatic
marketing
um
well that's that's a great question so
yep we're docker and we are the world's
first global physician programmatic
platform um what does that mean so if
you look at physicians or doctors
um you know it's it's not a unique
profession but it's it's it's you know
it's one of those professions where you
need to constantly
be up to date on what's happening you
know you could have qualified as a
doctor 40 years ago and medicine is very
different
you know today than it was last year let
alone 40 years ago so a big part of your
job as a physician you know is continual
medical education and making sure you're
up to date with the latest therapies
treatments all that kind of good stuff
and to do that you know they have to go
and find that information um and then
you have on the other side of the
equation you have like uh the big pharma
brands the big medical device companies
the companies that are really investing
in the r d to progress medicine and they
want to communicate you know all the
great stuff they're doing the research
development side all these new things
they're launching to improve patient
outcomes so really what we do is we we
are a platform that sits in between you
know a life science company that wants
to potentially educate a physician on
the latest
treatment or therapy and and the
physician themselves um
and we do that in a programmatic
environment um what programmatic means
really means just using programs um to
market or automatize automation um so if
you think about how a well our lives are
kind of dominated by by digital now so
we're we're talking now by a video
conference very digital so you think
about how a doctor goes about their
day-to-day
you know they may go oh well you know
i'll log in you know it's probably when
you go to the doctor it's a lot like
when i go you know they'll be talking to
you from behind a computer screen
tapping away notes into your electronic
health record yeah that's a digital
touch point for a doctor they may go to
a medical journal to read up on some of
the latest
the latest research they may go to a
continual medical a medical education
site to take some accumulate credits um
they may go to a
a networking site there's all these
different different digital touch points
and there's so much
you know opportunity well so much data a
swimming around in you know in terms of
what are they doing right there and then
and you know it really is how do you put
the the right message in front the right
person at the right time and
programmatic just allows us to harness
all that in real time so
you know if
one physician is on the british medical
journal reading a particular article we
could serve that position a completely
different message from the next perverse
next
physician that actually sees that page
in real time you know they could be
standing stand by side with their
laptops and see different messages based
on their interest or or behavior so
really
we connect life science brands with with
physicians and we do it in a very very
targeted surgical way take me back to
the personality of a physician because i
think what you're mentioning here is
super super interesting because i'm
thinking about myself for example as an
engineer and i'm thinking about you know
some ways in which i get updated as an
engineer very similar to a physician i
can be trained as an engineer but now i
have to be up to date with the evolving
um you know languages and the evolving
tools that have at my disposal and it's
quite difficult but what what is it
about the physician day-to-day or
perhaps personality that lends itself to
saying okay there's this niche market
here that there's a large enough
opportunity to create a you know
this a company like docaire that is
tailored for them
yeah that was that's that's a brilliant
question so um
traditionally
um
you know this kind of like education
piece on you know what the latest
advancements coming out from like life
science um was done by sales reps yeah
you know and they would they would go
around and they would visit doctors and
hospitals and surgeries
you know they'd go in and they'd spend
an hour or however long educating the
doctor you know here's the latest
journals here you know physically you
know giving them reading material things
like that um you know
healthcare is very very um
it's a very busy lifestyle should we say
you know doctors are very busy people
and that's only going one way
so it's been getting harder and harder
for them to dedicate time
to spend with reps versus patients and
then you have you know a global pandemic
that you know locks down
the entire world like you know try and
get a rep in to see a doctor in this
environment
and you know that's really accelerated
things so they're spending more and more
well they have less and less time
to actually spend with a physical rep
but they have more and more digital
touch points
so it's about you know
catching them you know because we're
looking
you know whether it be a point of care
platform so whether they're using an
electronic health record or the
prescribing app or you know whether on a
journal or an education website because
we know the environment they're in
we can be quite structured and you know
pushing those little messages out that
like oh it's the exact right context you
know our big
usp
is you know we are engaging those
doctors when they're in full work mode
when they are you know if you need to
talk to a cardiology about a specific
uh topic within cardiology
we can put that message you know in that
place you know if you want to
if you want to talk to a general
physician
around um
coupons or copay cars to subsidize a
patient's prescription costs you know in
the us we can do that because
at patient intake
the platform you know they'll know the
insurer and then if they prescribe a
certain medication you know we're not
going behind the hipaa wall or taking
any pii or anything like that because
we're in that environment we can
suddenly say oh you just prescribed x
did you know that you can hand out this
um this coupon
you know physicians love it patients
love it you know it's it's good for
everyone
is there any factor of building trust
with a visit with the physicians as
you're built as you know docker is
running today is there any
form of trust that needs to be built
here well what 100
trust is the key
key to everything i find
my background um
my background was uh search and then uh
did more broadly sort of digital media
across all formats and then i went and
worked to experian on the data side for
a while before
going over to a company named pulsepoint
that sort of pivoted into health about
five years ago and i would say
throughout my whole sort of digital
journey going from
selling media to selling data
to then getting involved in advertising
technology startups and the health
sector is trust powers everything so we
we are sort of almost an intermediary
marketplace the relation the physician
has the relationships
with the electronic health record
platform or the the journal publisher
but we then want to have a relationship
you know with with that that publisher
or platform
to help build the trusted with the
position every time the physician goes
to that platform we want them to be
getting value you know we don't want you
know the early days of uh programmatic
advertising on on the general internet
i'm sure a lot of people had that
experience where they were stalked
around the internet
by an ad for a pair of shoes or
something like that that you probably
purchased but the ad followed you around
for six weeks you know we don't want
that
creepy stalkery um
feeling and we also we also don't want
to hammer people with ads we want to be
very as i say very surgical
and provide valuable clinical messaging
so
that's the side we talked to
um with the um with the the supply side
so the relationships with the the
physicians so we want to enhance the
trust
those partners have with the physician
by adding valuable content to their
platforms and then the other side of the
equation we definitely need to build
trust um with the life science companies
so you know the pharma brands the
medical device companies because it this
is a highly regulated um industry
you know and if you get it wrong
you know there can be very big fines you
know if if you promote
promote something in a market where it's
not you know not
um
not approved to be promoted or
you met you promote it for a
it may be approved in that market but if
you promote it for something it's not
approved for and various other different
things so
i'd say on on that side of the equation
so on the demand side uh with our with
our clients their trust is is paramount
because
the low bar isn't saying oh well we
understand all the regulation and we're
completely compliant the low bar is we
understand all the
uh regulation we're completely compliant
and we can
we can you know articulate to you in a
simple easy to understand way because
the low bar is convincing the compliance
team whether it you know at the brand
that hey you know
this is great my marketing team love it
it's innovative you know i'm going to
get my right message out to the doctor
drive engagement it's going to be great
uh and then you get this compliance team
like are we going to get a huge fine for
doing this and you have to be able to
you know clearly articulate to those
guys so trust is
is paramount
you know looking at at my role
specifically you know we're we
we launched originally in the indian
market which was which for me joining
the business was was a massive a massive
thing because
there are a few companies doing
programmatic advertising in the health
space in the us
the u.s is somewhat of a unique market
in terms of the regulation
and how you can advertise to physicians
and patients um
new zealand's the only other market that
really works like the us the rest of the
world you can only
advertise any mess well you can only
show any message interview with
prescription drugs
in two doctors in very specific
environments
um
so you know we have to be able to kind
of
clearly articulate that and the fact
that we did it in india and then we went
to the us
and now in coming to europe it's very
easy for me to say well you know i'm
just layering on it's like well first
thing i only work with
endemic environments i only work
with places where doctors go i'm not on
the open internet i'm not you know
showing an advert or a message to a
doctor when he's on cnn.com you know
that is not what i do you know i'm only
on an environment only a doctor would go
to preferably behind a login
um you know and building that trust and
layering on the innovation because if we
you know programmatic advertising
it's probably 10 15 years old
and if we try to go
in at a million miles an hour i said
right we can do all this great stuff
immediately
some people would get excited and then
everyone with a legal background
would slam the door on our faces because
it'd be like whoa so it's about building
trust and then layering on
um you know innovation around that um
and keeping things simple
so is is it something special about
physicians where
where they are right now an ideal
audience for such a thing or or do you
see this as something that can be
replicated or something that can be
leveraged for a variety of other
professions that in a similar nature
require that constant updating um
so
yeah yeah yes
you could you know if you look at how
digital advertising works you know with
in the consumer world
so much innovation around personalized
ads you know there's there's regulation
eight that like out there like gdpr and
the eu
yeah that means companies have to use
data in in responsible ways
but then you look at you look at how
much
um
just how much gdp goes into healthcare
um you know how much
r d budget goes in how much advertise
you know it's a huge use industry
it's very underinvested in digital
because as i mentioned earlier it was
very rep driven
and then also if you look at the amount
of data
available
you know they're not the biggest
audiences in the world it's like 1.1
1.2 maybe a million doctors in the us
1.7 give or take you know in in in
europe including the uk
but
the amount of information because you
know with digital going crazy in terms
of the applications of all these
different digital platforms that people
use to make their lives easier you know
and doctors uh
you know and um
digital health records and things you
know with you know that coming out the
states being pushed sort of globally the
data is all there that you know you can
build these very
very meaningful
kind of moments where you can engage and
interact with a physician because you
know maybe 10 years ago um we might not
have been able to do what what we're
doing now um
so yeah i think the the opportunities
it's a huge market it's massively
underinvested in digital
and we're now at a point where the
technology and the data it's all kind of
there
that if you you know if you understand
the regulation and you do it in a
responsible way
you know we can really accelerate um you
know what's happening and
really for you know our kind of vision
is we want to
we want to empower
physicians you know with
with the most up-to-date information so
they can do their their jobs better you
know it's not around you know we're
we're not an advertising company you
know we serve advertising and
promotional clinical messaging but
really we want to
we want to be a sort of data and
insights company we want to understand
you know
how particular physicians behave
um how particular brands
you know should be thinking around not
just well where you know i want to get
in front of cardiologists where do i do
that yes we can do that but
what is it you're you're bringing out is
it just cardiology are there other
kind of specialities that overlap that
you should be considering and really
sort of you know become special advisors
to
to the brands on on
the audience they should go after and
then the best way to find that audience
and and engage them digitally and as
as the world accelerates with digital
i'm sure we'll we won't have many dull
days in terms of innovation
where's your passion coming for all this
you know this deep understanding
obviously you're
very curious about what you do and you
truly believe in what you do where is
this coming from
um
so i suppose i kind of as i say i i
started my journey sort of working at
yahoo
yeah um selling you know selling search
and then i started selling digital media
and
you know it's i i really enjoyed my time
there
um
and then i went and did a little bit in
the data side i kind of without knowing
it sort of touched all these different
elements within the digital sphere
i put myself in a good position to go to
a startup and then i got employed by a
company called pulsepoint
i never really look back in terms of big
companies are great but little companies
when you're building something was
brilliant and that kind of
you know identifying a problem or a need
or an issue
and then building something to solve it
or disrupt i absolutely love it um you
know the best bit about my job
is i almost feel like um
you know there's a series of puzzle
pieces that i need to i need to find and
then i need to put them together to make
you know make the picture that we're
looking to get to and i really i really
enjoy that kind of
yeah building and
orchestrating and you know building it
you know coming up with a vision
building a team and then and then
executing it and
you know when i was younger showing ads
on the internet um that was great for
paying my mortgage and now i'm a little
bit older i kind of want to
i want to have something a little bit
more more meaningful um to look back on
and
you know
working in the you know like healthcare
i think
you know the us the uk most of europe
doesn't work as well as it could and
anything we can do to bring efficiency
to it um you know it's something you can
kind of i can look back on and be
be kind of proud of
i i love it you know if you're looking
now with your you know your what you do
today and the impact that you have is is
you're talking quite a bit about the
impact on the physicians and the market
and then obviously the ripple effect is
huge towards you know the end then
customers is that is that a big part of
the journey as well you know the way
that you know through educating the
market and through providing you know
the the access to these new technologies
you're by default then and the transit
of property you're making an impact then
on the people that are then getting
affected through these physicians
no definitely definitely um you know
if you if you pull it all back
it's all about you know delivering you
know a big buzzword in in the healthcare
industry's patient outcomes but that
that's what it's you know all about it's
you know how
you know and not even i think probably
delivering sort of patient outcome it's
like someone goes to the doctor you know
you want to get them well you can even
go beyond that it's like well how do we
you know as a society keep people
healthier
so you're almost like preventative care
so they don't really go to the doctor as
much and you know
just looking at you know how
interconnected everything is digitally
now if we can harness the power of that
you know like i say in a in a
responsible way
to deliver
the right information to the right
people
you know in the right moment so it has
the greatest impact
you know it's all around you know or if
we can make people healthier
you know there'll be less strain
on health systems and there'll be more
money to go into
you know
well
investment in health care you know make
you know once that gets to where it
should be you know just investment in in
in other things and quality of life but
yeah it's it's definitely a
a big thing for me now i'm a little bit
older i really like quite like the the
kind of vision of having a more
meaningful impact on the world well it
definitely sounds like you you do have
that with the duck here and i was
fascinated hearing about you know your
outlook on the on the market and what's
happening today and the way that
information flows and the different
opportunities there are
so gareth i really want to thank you for
for joining me in these 20 minutes this
was very very enjoyable it went by very
very quick
but i i loved hearing about the journey
and about what the domain and thank you
very much for your time and for the
impact no worries thank you for having
me thank you